nigeria se enfrenta a otra masacre más
de un centenar de civiles fueron
asesinados este fin de semana en un
ataque en los arrozales del estado de
borno donde suele actuar el grupo
terrorista boko haram
tras el suceso docenas de personas se
han reunido para enterrar los cuerpos
nos encontramos con tanta gente huyendo
de nuestra aldea sin saber a dónde iban
algunos incluso estaban inconscientes
incendiaron una gran cantidad de arroz
cosechado realmente necesitamos
oraciones sólo dios puede salvarme en su
si bien nadie se ha atribuido el crimen
boko haram ha efectuado matanzas de este
tipo en el pasado y se mantiene muy
activo en la región desde hace una
década por lo que muchas fuentes le
señalan como responsable
boko haram es un grupo yihadista que
reivindica el establecimiento de la ley
islámica en nigeria y por ello se ha
cobrado la vida de numerosos militares y
civiles
boko haram mató a muchos de los nuestros
y decenas de personas fueron masacradas
necesitamos ayuda necesitamos armas y
hombres armados porque tenemos jóvenes
que pueden ser voluntarios para cuidar
de nuestros granjeros mientras trabajan
por favor por favor por el amor de dios'
la gente de la zona se enfrenta a dos
opciones quedarse en casa y morir de
hambre o cultivar sus tierras y
exponerse a ser asesinados por los
insurgentes debido a esta situación de
inseguridad y a las inundaciones los
precios de los alimentos en nigeria han
aumentado drásticamente en el último año
en una lucha por sobrevivir los locales
han pedido a las fuerzas armadas que los
protejan de los atentados